[Applaudissements]
vous avez une large campagne à blanc
alors ni norbert je te demande
ces versions des racks était content que
ça tout le monde sa république ouais
bah si tout le monde va bien on peut
commencer cyril vous commencez à pas mal
vous y connaître en politique on le sait
la petite question du jour est ce que
vous connaissez aurélien pradié mehr sur
highway bras c'est là qu'on va vous êtes
un fin connaisseur moi je ne connaissais
pas est pareil accordez-moi le
connaissez pas fradier m'a dit non un
peu penser à ce mec en soirée qui est
toujours là mais qu'on connaît pas il
est sympa et super sympa mais on ne
connaît pas et bon du coup moi j'ai
découvert cette semaine c'est un député
du lot et c'est un truc de ouf on l'a vu
absolument partout
bonjour aller en troisième pour sera
bourré lien pas dillon soir jour en rien
pradier bonjourbonjour aurélien pradié
jours et quand je dis partout c'est
vraiment mais vraiment partant contre
villard on pourra jouer avec aurélien
aurélien vous venez d'où aurélien
mobily la ministre de l'écologie était
invité sur europe 1 bonjour mardi au
chili je jure madame la ministre oui il
a bien fallu rappeler son poste parce
qu'elle s'est un peu trop chauffé et
elle a bien galéré pour se rattraper je
crois que c'est comme ça qu'on peut
avancer moi je suis là quand la la
[Applaudissements]
un ministre de la république
bon pour sa défense n'était pas la seule
sur elle c'est jordan bardel a lui aussi
fait une belle boulette
nos policiers aujourd'hui font un
travail déplorables un travail admirable
pardon un travail admirable mais dans
des conditions qui sont déplorables en
tout cas si vous aviez le moral cette
semaine c'est sûrement que vous n'avez
pas vu l'interview d'oran vergès sur
sonic team pédocriminalité assassiné
computer victimes tuées suicide victimes
d'abus sexuels merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
cirilli reste plus que quelques mois oui
prendre pendant leurs deux garçons
l'ampleur au début c'était bien mais il
manquait un tout petit peu de
personnalité et oui ça commence à
me rappelle que je suis consultant à
audio chez qui mais arrêtez - ça c'est
vrai que vous ne croyez pas le tour je
voulais dit vous êtes quoi je fais
vraiment des conférences souvent sur les
médias sur l'air des médias
bien franchement je comprend mais vous
comprenez vraiment j'en ai pas lourd là
non mais franchement je trouve qu'il a
une très bonne connaissance des médias
je trouve ça très bien le fascinant
franchement à la prochaine fois vous me
direz je viendrai vous voir c'est vrai
bail avec grand plaisir assez gentil
mais c'est payant
alors appel que j'attends du road book
and vous pourrez toujours attendre en
média training de m'acheter mon rire
d'ailleurs non mais dites moi mais je
n'ai pas de nous le donner faut qu'on
l'achète je suis rentré dans la loge il
avait dix way s'est dit est ce que je
prône à bas je peux en prendre un tu as
vu touche pas au grisbi [ __ ] t'as mis
la main dessus
[Applaudissements]
c'est venu tout cas ni la dpica goethe à
18 le dédicacer je te dédie casser tout
de suite
comme était vraiment lire merci mais et
je peux dire que j'ai vu laurent ruquier
est un ami j'adore loin et qui m'a dit
j'ai vraiment aimé libre c'était pas
pour la lazio s'est méfié j'aime
beaucoup et c'est vrai qu'il était
sincère il y livre et bah ouais bon
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup de points
très bien comment
c'est vrai qu'ils me les niveaux
moi j'ai bouquiner lassus la whey julien
bouquiner
s'est refusé de ne pas aimer
[Applaudissements]
le dis c'est quoi ça ça veut rien dire
c'est bon c'est de moi c'est de moi guy
de hanouna
reste plus que quelques mois avant
l'élection présidentielle la campagne
est officiellement lancée et il ya de
plus en plus de candidats parmi eux il
ya marine le pen et j'ai retrouvé une
interview d'elle dit qui date d'il ya
quelques semaines on la voyait tout
tranquille tout gentil
l'habitude je ne sais pas chambouler je
suis calme
et donc aussi bien c'est
bon ça c'était avant parce que cette
semaine à l'été sur bfm et on sent que
l'échéance approche c'est pas la même
marina est revenue à l'essentiel la
france n'est plus une terre
d'immigration et l'immigration
immigration renvoyés chez eux
l'immigration immigration des étrangers
l'immigration les étrangers mollo là
dans ce monde de brutes clément bonne
secrétaire d'état était dans bourdin
direct pour partager ses plus belles
rimes prise
[Musique]
ce n'est pas un sujet technique et moins
sujets juridiques c'est un sujet
éminemment politique non ça dépend ce
qu'on appelle le moratoire oui mais ce
que je ne veux pas que faire croire
qu'on fasse croire moi je suis ministre
je vais rencontrer mes homologues jeu
n'auront jamais le dialogue j'ai eu la
grosse laine d'écouter toute interview
de xavier bertrand sur tf1 joue en bas
du coup voici ce qu'il fallait retenir
de son ide est un lieu où ces gâteaux
bonsoir bienvenue bertrand bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
est ce que vous allez vous soumettre au
vote des militants oui merci
prévu aller aux questions et puis les
politiques et à fond cette semaine et on
a eu droit à leur meilleure expression
regarde ce qu'on veut c'est ne pas
mettre tous nos oeufs dans le même
panier on mettra le paquet non ces
poteaux mouiller le pad vague ces
tripatouillages comme on dit dans ma
famille on est des mousses nous 50 50 de
bon aloi en semblant faut pas jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain il a volé un
oeuf un an et demi après il a volé un
buzz
[Musique]
juste avant a juste avant la météo des
réseaux actifs et syrie la semaine
dernière vous avez fait un vrai marathon
des plateaux s'en souvient à croire que
vous avez quelque chose à vendre j'ai
rien à vendre laguna
le message est passé bah oui j'espère et
vous manquez plus qu'un plateau celui
d'europe 1 et du coup quand vous êtes
arrivé là bas avait après votre long
marathon bas vous étiez complètement sur
la west et le matin j'étais fera car ce
qui al'air dition du cerf ont de hong
kong pas non plus aux dires des
températures qui baisse ni des
eaux-de-vie l'iphone il ya cyril hanouna
qui parle de d'agora
le réveil était trop tôt vous aviez
l'air un peu déconnecté qu'est ce qu'ils
disent d'ailleurs certains sondages tant
et si bien qu'on a des gens qui
s'informent généralement par les canaux
classiques qui eux
poser question ça dépend d'ailleurs
énormément de l'exposition médiatique ce
qui d'ailleurs il est fonctionnel et
périph
martin
en fait pour l'instant n'est pas
réellement d'enfoncer le
moment donné vous avez complètement
lâché la sphère rendre compte du fait
que c'est pas du tout les missions
[Applaudissements]
vous l'annoncer c'était ma dernière
matinale a chuté fracasse franchement
qu'est la nasse mais était très sympa
vraiment on s'ennuie comme ça quand on a
invité dans l'émission tu fais côté des
matines non non non non non c'était très
sympa mais c'est vrai que c'est avec toi
je me suis régalé j'ai connu un
politologue magnifique c'est vrai vous
avez détailleront que j'embrasse
d'ailleurs et sonia mabrouk magnifique
dans ce dessein pas franchement c'est
sympa mais très tôt chez la dernière
fois qu'ils me diront sur une matinée
[Applaudissements]
ya plus d'audace et sûr voilà bah oui
mais attendez retour va remonter est
vrai mais ça mettra des lumières partout
savourer ce n'était pas moi la rage pas
sur europe1 toi quoi pourquoi pas parce
que c'est la famille d'importants la
famille oui la famille c'est ça la magie
sont tous la famille bonatti faible
c'est la famille moi je
l'adoré j'écoutais ça mais moi c'était
au plus bas j'étais là c'est ça les
vrais fans et les supporteurs
tout le monde est la famille mais non
mais cherche du taf attendez moi je n'ai
rien à voir avec ça va nous demander
quelque chose au cas où quelqu'un écoute
n'importe quoi j'adore vos l'origine
j'adore europe un jeu rodez mais europe
1 raymond merde ça n'a rien à mes
convictions je lés 6 et 10 arnaud
lagardère le patron d'europe 1 appelez
le 1 et le voilà plus que le numéro où
les chapelles
nom rappelle celui qui a après bassil
arnaud lagardère a gardé sa vie bah
voila voila c'est de vous les chapelles
ramzi khiroun afflux bien ah oui alors
c'est le patron du groupe l'a vraiment
vous m'avez une mais une émission de
radio alors je peux essayer de voir
faire ce que je peux faire mais tu sais
faire des tu m'emmerdes tous ses pairs
menés que j'appelle ou quand ça c'est
vrai beaucoup mais ce côté là de venir
ici un
nom ça j'aimerais beaucoup qu'on a
vraiment rencontré une fois une soirée
alors il est certain que people 1 oui
vous voulez que voulez quoi alors dites
moi mais c'est ça mathieu qui quémandent
mais sans ça parce que tu veux à lyon il
faut du pognon du profit ainsi fiona
alors non j'aimerais beaucoup une
émission alors sans me vanter j'aimerais
une sorte de pascal praud pour les
jeunes mais ce que je veux dire des
sujets sorti des années sur virgin radio
pas mal pas mal pas mal et qui s'appelle
virgin radio peu importe le support
le patron de virgin voulait que
j'appelle à ça je viens mouly qui alors
bah ça c'est très bien vune qui celui
qui veut de moi
les sympathies aux constances maquiller
la patronne des antennes et tendance
mais sa
voisine prodige belge à leur constance
benqué c'est quoi c'est non c'est non
les présidents des chapelles chalet
président sur messages directs potes
appelez moi le
quotidien
oui merci très vite elle a dit
constance ma chérie c'était cyril
rappelle moi je suis en émission là chez
un mec là qui veut absolument faire de
la radio là chez toi ils me cassent la
tête
tu peux me rappeler
t'embrasse fort ma chérie j'espère tu
vas bien est inquiète pas y'a pas de
problème pour la dernière fois et mon
nom bien sûr j'aurais aimé te voir mais
malheureusement tu ne pouvais pas en se
verra une prochaine fois le mec c'est
mathieu de lambeaux tapez sur google
je suis désolé je suis désolé s'est très
bien vendu c'est très bien mais qu'est
ce qu'est ce qu'il a déjà fait de la
radio voulait qu apple qui n'a c'est pas
bien ce que tu as fait mais personne ne
sait qui on
est
passé au dessus passer au dessus de tout
on voulait vraiment qui s'appelle ou pas
oui d'ailleurs rendez vous une fois avec
lui je vais taper même coupé numéro deux
chez lagardère ouais tu n'as pas le tout
de suite et numéro deux gardiens
l'appelle tout de suite le vice mais
vas-y vraiment à ramzi faut comprendre
et j'appelle
rappellera aussi la ligne d'apple tv
vous et bardos malin oui bien sûr elles
peuvent donc construire votre avenir la
malle un par deux aides
ça me répondent ensuite les personnes
mourir au pouvoir oui il m'a non ils se
doivent se dire il ya quelque chose à
nous dresser ça mais bon tu allais je
crois que tu le numéro le plus
angoissant de la place de leurs
rames dit frérot c'est moi rappelle moi
je suis à l'antenne fait que je te parle
d'un truc il ya mathieu delormeau grand
talent qui voudraient faire de la radio
au sein du groupe tu vois je dis grand
talent le public rigole de tous
rappelle moi au et
qu'on voit ce qu'on peut faire de lui je
sais pas si t'as pas déprogrammé au
local ou même heure
[Rires]
même même si elles radio dans ton
immeuble ou quelque chose comme ça ça me
dit oui merci je tombe à l'affiché des
mes thèmes je t'embrasse
mais
je pense qu'on a je pense qu'on est pas
mal allez mes débuts ça ira nommé début
maintenant on va voir tour va voir
d'érable avec ma vie je vais faire ça va
ça va là
une réponse de granby
le un des grands patrons à la du groupe
lagardère way qui me dit cheikh cyrine
mathieu veut faire de la radio je
l'entends peux tu déjà l'envoyer dans un
centre de radiologie pour commencer
[Applaudissements]
quel est donc le centre de radiologie
très pensé voilà
voilà
c'est un beau bébé d'un mois début oui
bah déjà un prénom oui c'est un bon
début et des podcasts
[Musique]
une chaîne youtube
[Rires]
un tour
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est pour toi ma
télé dans 15 ans quotidienne ouais ouais
avec qui
caractérise le mag non mais c'est un
appareil c'est vrai quand je suis allé
chercher je proviens quand j'ai été
recruté mathieu de l'enm où je viens on
avait rendez vous chez ba didier
production absolument
il ya quelque chose s'appelle existe je
vais vous dire ouais sa solitude
la vérité j'avais demandé à benoît qui
avait dit non à capucine qui avaient des
noms haché public avait dit non dans le
mac débat est restée moi pas du tout non
non non c'est vous que je voulais au
départ il savait mais je me suis dit tu
vous dire je me suis dit est-ce que je
vais taper tout de suite la star aller
et je les fais je les fais sont dit
croire vous êtes vraiment mais vraiment
et j'avais rendez vous avec vous je suis
arrivé
une demi-heure avant pour préparer ce
rendez vous alors on attend peu après
j'ai attendu une heure vingt dans l'eau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
la réceptionniste qui a fait monsieur
de de romo vous êtes sûr que vous avez
rendez vous aujourd'hui colonna ah non
non non et vous drapez ce rendez vous on
s'est dit plein de choses à ben vous
étiez en ce que tu t'es mis à cette
histoire est devenue une amitié
énorme entre nous comme la banane de
tout à l'heure
de cette phrase quand tu m'avais dit
j'espère grandir grandir tu auras ton
émission
c'était il ya sept ans ouais
[Rires]
j'avais jamais donné de date
tu vois ce qu'il adore mon petit doigt
dans ces pièges bas à oui alors
s'affronter mais avec bernard
on va laisser à penser d'abord
lancé en éclaireur
tués après allez-vous tuerie bon si je
vous dit tout ce soir après les
matinales j'ai encore craqué je suis
retourné sur les réseaux avec vous
connaissez c'est la meilleure c'est les
meilleures vidéos ça
fait deux heures tranquilles et la
musique inadec s'inquiète pas fait les
meilleurs vidéos sur les réseaux c'est
la météo des nations il faut un beau
mais j'ai retrouvé le pépito notre
enfance elle n'a pas pris une ride
non
pierrot
débat toujours
à bordeaux si vous croisez un chien sans
son maître ben vous inquiétez pas c'est
normal il se fait juste un petit kiff il
veut parvenir depuis dix minutes je tire
le plus petit bibelot
jogo allez bon für alle et non je joue
leiris django django
rouillac on dit merci à ce mec qui nous
permet d'apprendre quelques mots
d'allemand un cross car qui
sème la panique avec ces rodéos urbains
[Musique]
je
l'union de gager trouver le mec qui
aggravent envie de se marier sa joie
et depuis les 30 km heure à paris ce
policier un peu plus de temps pour qu'il
fait
c'est
[Musique]
je
et enfin ajaccio tout le monde a droit à
un petit moment de détente c'est beau
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi
[Applaudissements]